Qatar used to be one of the poorest countries
in the world, and now it's one of the richest.
So how on earth did that happen? Back in
the day, most Qataris were part of nomadic
tribes like the Bedouin. Everyone else in the
country basically lived in fishing villages,
and the biggest industry was pearl hunting.
Pearl hunting is like insanely dangerous and
exhausting work. In the heat of the summer, these
men would row their boats out to the open ocean,
they would put wooden clips around their
nose, and they would tie themselves to a
rock and then jump into the ocean for minutes
at a time to collect oysters. They would come
up and hope that there were pearls in them. The
pearl industry eventually got crushed. World War
I happened. And then in 1939, everything changed
when oil was discovered. Qatar hit the fossil fuel
jackpot not just with oil, but also when they
discovered that they literally are sitting on
the world's largest natural gas field. So,
yeah, thanks to the Industrial Revolution,
everything changed. And now Qatar's rich
as $%#@ I mean, just look at their cities.